it's lovely to see you here Kate at
London form comic-con have you been
enjoying today oh I've been having a
great time it's my first convention so I
don't know what to expect and I had no
idea this water would access then it's
been really really nice meeting people
and yeah it's been lovely had a
fantastic season ongoing affair it was
revealed that you'd not only killed your
husband your own husband that you framed
the Lannisters as well what did you
think when you got that screw well I
yeah it was quite a shock but it's also
such a pleasure to play a character like
Liza because she saw kind of off the
scale and saw damage that it was a joy
just to get to play all these different
things and also to know all along and
tell it was revealed at the moon door
exactly what she'd been doing and how
much she was involved in everything so
it's been brilliant
I mean Littlefinger you love him so much
obviously what is it about him that you
think Liza finds so irresistible I don't
know but you know what lies has been in
love with Littlefinger since she was a
teenager and he was our first and only
love and he's constantly played out all
through our life and she just yeah she's
just besotted by him I don't know why
but it's just always been besotted by
him and to her death she was besotted by
oh but ya know yeah she's just
everything that she did and all the
terrible things she did what all for him
so he's quite a player doesn't he you
mentioned the death scene there which is
quite something wasn't it tell us a
little bit about filming mode oh it was
wonderful filming the desi naturally was
Spain Aldi and we had in the moondoor
bed clash mat so I get pushed backwards
onto the clash mat and then separately
were filmed be hanging on a orbitty cold
there's a harmless thing up in the air
and then they filmed me from under me
and then flicked it so I found it really
anxious and even as an actor seen how
because I was like how will they fell me
fall and so I found that oh and just Oh
great to have a day like that you know
it was wonderful what was it been like
playing such an unstable character as
Liza because you know one minute she's
giving Sun some lemon cakes and next
minute she's bending her finger back or
throwing around the door I know see I
see Liza as a really damaged women who
when Liza was a teenager she was a
really sweet ghetto and then because of
what happened with Littlefinger and
because of all the miscarriages and
stillbirths ended up really damaged so I
know she's a character that people love
to hate but I'm always like oh she's
almost understood but she is an actor
she's great because you're playing all
these extremes and you can switch from
one to the other and there's not many
characters I know that I could ever have
the freedom to do that so she was a
great character to play I mean suddenly
obviously we lost you now but would you
like to see happening in Game of Thrones
going forward oh my gosh I don't know
books are so many characters and so much
that could happen I would like to see a
little finger Gettys come up and but I
don't know because I haven't read beyond
this I don't actually know what happens
to him but I think he's do some payback
definitely and to cease and are having a
bit of an easier time because she's had
such a rough time up tornado's so yeah
but I would like to see a little finger
to meet some good Italy and I finally
Kate what can we look forward to from
you next you said you've been filming I
have I've just finished two independent
movies one called the witch which are
filmed in Canada and I've just come back
from France from film and a film called
couple and a hall about a couple who
live in a hall and a forest so I think
they should be out next year
you